Apple has rejected the binding of isaac
rebirth from their app store allegedly
cheated depiction of violence and
appease towards children this news comes
via a tweet from Tyrone Rodriguez who
founded Binding of Isaac rebirth
publisher Nicholas the tweet features a
screenshot displaying apples rejection
of the app and Rodriguez's less than
impressed comment on the situation The
Binding of Isaac rebirth is a new
version of the original 2011 game
created by Super Meat Boy designer
Edmund McMillen oddly and iOS version
had not been officially announced before
this story came to light although
McMillan said previously that he was
exploring the idea The Binding of Isaac
which is rated M was also blocked from
launching on 3ds due to its cloaked
questionable religious content if you
are to where the game has you control a
child who's trying to escape his
murderous mother after God command to
sacrifice Nintendo did eventually permit
the game to launch on its platforms
uncensored let me know how you feel
about this one and we'll keep you
updated on how it unfolds on gamespot